yesterday Donald Trump's attorney
general Jeff session testified before
the Senate Intelligence Committee the I
guess now de-facto lead congressional
investigation on Russia after the house
panel became an absolute embarrassment
in sessions is caught up sort of in two
strands of the Trump Russia scandal
number one Trump associates
communicating with Russia before the
election of which he is one and Donald
Trump suspected interference with the
FBI's investigation into Trump Russia
collusion so Jeff Sessions showed up he
took an oath to swear to tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help him God which he accepted
he took questions about both of these
issues yesterday and number one what did
we really learn we learned that Jeff
Sessions is the most forgetful person
maybe in all of Washington DC we'll get
to that in a little bit and I ended up
being completely right that sessions was
going to show up and openly and properly
answer questions which make him look
good which are never talked to this
person never talked to that person no
collusion didn't know what was going on
there my refusal was solid and upheld
and all of a sudden when the questions
are ones that might make him not look
quite so good he's either going to not
remember or refuse to answer and I told
you last week NSA director Mike Rogers
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates acting FBI director Andrew McCabe
an attorney assistant attorney general
rod Rosenstein showed up before the
Senate Intel panel and they said oh
we're just not going to answer certain
questions and when angus King a senator
on the panel said well what's your legal
basis for not answering these questions
dan coats for example said I don't think
I have a legal basis I'm just not going
to answer and amazingly Jeff Sessions
cited last week's testimony as to why he
believes it's normal not to answer
questions when he doesn't feel like it
I'm going to get to that a little bit
later first listen to how Jeff Sessions
answers questions about credible
allegations that have been made against
him during his confirmation hearing to
become AG session specifically
volunteered I
met with Russians during the campaign we
later found out that wasn't true he did
meet at least two times with Russian
ambassador Sergey kishle a concessions
admitted it but tried to spin it by
saying I wasn't lying because kids lyac
didn't talk about the campaign I thought
we were talking about other surrogates
even though it doesn't really explain
why sessions didn't disclose that when
he was applying for a security clearance
but in any case at yesterday's hearing
he continued this unbelievable story
about how he didn't lie at his
confirmation hearing I was responding to
this allegation that we had met
surrogates had been meeting with the
Russians on a regular basis it simply
did not occur to me to go further than
the context of the question and to list
any conversations that I may have had
with Russians in routine situations as I
had had many routine situations calm
meetings with other front of your time
totally not credible I mean just reading
a poorly written script to try to
explain the unexplainable and the
original report was sessions had two
meetings with Russian officials sessions
denied the allegation that he had a
third undisclosed meeting with Keyes
lyac at a DC hotel in April of last year
and sessions said well I forgot that
kiss lyac was at that get-together if he
was there I may have talked to him I
don't remember / I don't know so when
you said you possibly had a meeting with
mr. kiss lyac what you did you mean you
possibly met him I didn't have any I
want more meeting with him ITT confident
of that but I may have had an encounter
during the reception that's the only
thing I cannot say with certainty I did
not reminds me of the way he answered
questions at the hearing for his federal
judgeship in 1986 which he ultimately
failed to get through successfully he
was brought face to face with things he
personally had said for example that the
NAACP and the Civil Liberties Union are
unamerican organizations these comments
that you could say about a County
organization that something I may have
said something like that
in a general way and that probably was
wrong everything that Jeff session said
about his meetings with the Russians was
qualified with maybe I don't know I
don't believe so I don't remember I
can't recall john mccain asked sessions
what he talked about with russian
ambassador sergei kiss lyac i don't I
just don't have a real recall of the
meeting I made I was not making a report
about it to anyone I just was basically
willing to meet and see on what he
discussed the response was I don't
recall more I don't remember with
Senator Camilla Harris Democrat from
California did you have any
communications with Russian officials
for any reason during the campaign that
have not been disclosed in public or to
this committee I don't recall it but I
have to tell you I cannot testify to
what was said as we were standing at the
revoked convention before the podium
where I spoke my mother so not only
don't have a detail memory of that okay
and I'm lying to your knowledge did you
have any communication with any Russian
businessmen or any Russian nationals I
don't believe I had any conversation
with Russian businessmen or Russian
nationals are you aware although a lot
of people were at the convention it's
conceivable it somebody there I had
enough just a few let me qualify it i if
you about all qualified you'll accuse me
of lying so I need to be correct as best
I can I want you to be I'm not able to
be rushed this fast it makes me nervous
the way he smiles at Kamel Harris in
this next clip if you're watching it
really just seems like he's messing with
her and he knows that he's deliberately
doing that I just don't know man are you
aware of any communications with other
Trump campaign officials and associates
that they had with Russian officials or
any Russian nationals I don't recall
that and are you aware of at this moment
right now I am NOT able to recall
whether or not what you said what you're
asking about may or may not have taken
place remind me never to meet with
surgery kiss react or any of these other
Russian officials because apparently
they're incredibly boring people nobody
can remember just nobody knows what did
we talk about did we even meet and the
only things Jeff Sessions seem to be
able to remember and Express super
clearly was that he didn't do anything
wrong
that part he was damn sure about and
when it came to whether or not he talked
to Russians about interfering with the
election all of a sudden he could
remember what was discussed in the
meetings take a look at this and I
participate and the suggestion that I
participated in any collusion that I was
aware of any collusion with the Russian
government to hurt this country which I
have served with honor for 35 years
yeah that part he's sure about that
didn't happen so that's that I don't
recall part of Jeff Sessions the most
forgetful guy on Capitol Hill but then
there's this other bogus thing he did
there's something called executive
privilege okay the president has the
ability to not answer certain questions
and settings like these by invoking what
is called executive privilege Trump knew
that this hearing was going on and he
opted not to invoke executive privilege
to prevent Jeff Sessions from talking
about certain things okay so to be clear
executive privilege was not invoked here
but what Jeff Sessions did when he
didn't want to answer certain questions
is say well out of respect for the
possibility that Donald Trump might in
the future want to invoke executive
privilege although he didn't actually
invoke it I'm not going to answer those
questions and it is just an incoherent
explanation as to why he's not going to
answer questions take a look at this mr.
Chen general thank you for joining us
today I respect your willingness to be
here thank you testified a few minutes
ago I'm not able to invoke executive
privilege that's up to the president has
the president invoked executive
privilege in the case of your testimony
here today he had not then what is the
basis of your refusal to answer these
questions senator cane the president has
a constitutional
and I but the president has asserted it
well Elgin you don't have the power to
assert these power of executive
privilege so what is the legal basis for
your refusal to answer these questions I
am protecting the right of the President
to exert it assert it if he chooses and
there may be other privileges that could
apply in this circumstance
unintelligible the president hasn't
asserted it I have no right to assert it
but I'm protecting the president's right
to may be asserted in the future legal
experts are saying this is not how
executive privilege works and Senator
Kamala Harris also tried asking jeff
sessions about this bizarre
defense for not answering questions
during the hearing is that policy in
writing somewhere I think so so did you
not consult it before you came before
this committee knowing we would ask you
questions well we we talked about the
policy is that it would be shown to you
the policy is based on the principle
that the president I'm not asking about
the principle I'm asking when my name
ask me questions and you would rely on
that policy did you not ask your staff
to show you the policy that would be the
basis for you refusing to answer jointed
whispery allowed so let's skip the last
couple clips which are less relevant Pat
sessions maintains what he didn't why at
any point he hasn't done anything wrong
but there's a lot of stuff he's not
willing to talk about and he maintains
that his recommendation to fire James
Comey didn't violate the recusal when
clearly it did he was under oath he
swore to tell the whole truth but he
wouldn't answer any questions about
conversations that he's had with Donald
Trump and by the way he has not done
anything to dispel any of the assertions
of James Comey corroborating some and
merely not addressing others he also is
in this very tough position though
because he doesn't want to upset Trump
right wants to allow Trump to live
another day and he also can't be caught
lying under oath again again right the
way you do that is just say you don't
remember because it's hard to prove that
you you forgot something it is one of
the most common legal tactics which is
who can prove you do remember something
you might have forgotten and it is
something that Jeff Sessions has taken
advantage of boldly and brazenly and we
really learned very little from this
hearing